[Music]  when most people think of south africa  they think about  safaris  for me south africa is all about its  amazing coastline  and incredible oceans  south africa is the meeting place of two  ocean giants  you have the cold atlantic you have the  warm indian ocean and you have this  incredibly  rugged and wild bit of coastline where  the oceans meet  together these two contrasting marine  environments create  one of the most unique and incredible  ocean habitats  in the world the sheer  diversity of life is incredible there's  nowhere else on this planet  where you can encounter such a diverse  array of marine life  with such ease and in such a short  period of time  [Music]  south africans are incredibly proud of  their marine heritage  and seem to be happiest when sharing  them  with the rest of the world  i've spent the last 20 years  photographing the world's oceans  and the south african coast is still  my favorite place on earth  you